Russia's defense minister Sergey shoigu
says Ukraine is planning to attack
Russian territory with NATO supplied
missiles he warned that if it happened
Moscow would retaliate
according to the information we have the
command of Ukraine's Armed Forces plans
to attack Russian territory including
Crimea with high Mars and Storm Shadow
missiles deployment of these missiles
beyond the zone of the special military
operation would mean full-scale
involvement of the United States and
Britain in the conflict this would
entail immediate strikes on
decision-making centers on Ukraine's
territory
for more on this let's speak to Julia
shop of Oliver in Moscow Yulia this
sounds like Russia saying that it has
red lines that must not be crossed in
this conflict
it does doesn't it a Russian defense
minister Sergey shogu has shed some
light on the plans of the Armed Forces
of Ukraine to strike at the territory of
Russia including Crimea he said that the
Western High Mars and Storm Shadow
missiles would be used by the ukrainians
and their Kia would use its Western kit
and Elite formations trained by NATO
Specialists so as a retaliatory measure
shoigu threatened to carry out immediate
strikes on decision-making centers in
Ukraine so there's been an immediate
reaction to those words in telegram
channels here experts say that Russia
always draws the so-called red lines
promising to punish Ukraine for its
actions and attacks but basically all it
does is keeping pounding Ukraine's
infrastructure and not just that on a
daily basis so now we just have to wait
and see what decision-making centers
will be targeted by Russia this time
around shoigu also noted that Ukrainian
troops were trying to attack in the
South Donetsk Donetsk and the perocia
directions and since June the 4th the
ukrainians have launched 263 attacks on
the positions of the Russian troops all
of the Ukrainian tanks were repelled and
as for the full involvement of the
United States and Britain in the
conflicts the Russian leadership has
many times stated that Russia resists
not just Ukraine but NATO as a whole
it's a hybrid war and all the NATO
countries are involved so nothing new
here again apart from Sergey Sergey
lavrov Russia's foreign minister has
just stated if NATO is against freezing
the conflict in Ukraine that means they
want to fight so Moscow is ready for
that too well I guess no analysis are
needed here basically according to all
the words and statements there is no end
in sight at least this hour
reporting from Moscow thank you very
much